but what I do know is
150,000 Nevada registered Republicans
stayed home and didn't vote in 2022 I
know that for a fact lost by 8,000
150,000 Republicans stayed home and it
gets worse because all of those eligible
voters in Nevada receive a ballot
whether or not they request one that
means that people were so demoralized
dejected in dispar or maybe they heard
from people don't vote by meal so they
didn't and they didn't even walk 10 ft
to their mailbox to drop it in 150,000
Oregon Oregon we lost by 62,000 votes in
the gubernatorial election
126,000 registered Oregonian Republicans
did not vote and they only a vote by
male State we could have a republican
governor in Oregon on the Left Coast
with all those hippies over there my
people had we actually just filled in a
meal and ballot and voted